the most amazing thing that i'm super
proud of it
and again is someone that comes from the
public policy world and
everything is is the fact that we give
the data to cities
and then the cities can make smart
decisions
about the public way welcome to 20
minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lumitec and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford the micro mobility revolution
is here and i had the unique pleasure of
speaking with yaniv rivlin
arguably one of the people that have
made this transformation not just in
israel
and the world meet yaniv rivlin yaniv is
byrd's general manager in israel and a
director in the global company
bird is the last mile electric vehicle
sharing company dedicated to bringing
affordable environmentally friendly
transportation solutions to communities
across the world
yaniv is responsible for leading the
successful adoption of burden israel
which has been acknowledged globally
including by the wall street journal
yahoo and newsweek
welcome to 20 minute leaders i'm so
honored and excited to have you here
i'm excited to be here thank you for the
invitation
and no no you invited me because the
only way that i got to this office was
through riding one of your scooters
so i need to thank you because you
actually are responsible for helping me
get to the office pretty much on a daily
basis
over the last six months and not just me
and but most of my friends and most of
the people that i see around
this area that are just driving these
beautiful scooters
it's a different world i don't think
anybody 10 years ago could even
imagine that this is how the streets of
tel aviv are going to look like and i'm
incredibly excited to to finally pick
the brain of one of the masterminds
behind this incredible adoption in tel
aviv
you're responsible for the successful
launch here uh with
it with some exciting news that by the
time this airs they will already
all be all over the news we want to say
them anyways but
in any case before we even talk about
this awesome thing you're doing
take me back a little bit and we'll
start with bolivia just because i have a
feeling it's a great story
olivia let's let's go back to uh
that was 2009 and so 2009 i was
traveling i just got accepted i finished
my undergrad in keeper u
and i just got accepted into an amazing
program called the
soviet scholars in montreal um
it's uh 12 young leaders from around the
world come live in a mansion for a year
and work on a year for reflection
everybody worked on a
project to change the world for a better
place and
super super incredible together with
mcgill university and others was really
incredible and before that
um i had a few months of gap so i
was going to travel with it with a dear
friend with the tomato that was
um the soviet the year before we met up
and
in peru we had a great time the first
month we were we were traveling around
peru
going for um hikes tracks everything
and had a great month or so and then our
next destination was
uh with bolivia and uh we
i i didn't feel you know a hundred
percent
um and i uh hopped on the plane and and
coughed around everybody that was there
that was around me
and then i landed and it was still
coughing
and i arrived to like the you know
immigration counter
and then i continue to the cough
and then they they went aside to uh to
talk i guess someone wrote
exactly how to huddle a little bit i was
like
i felt i didn't feel that well so i
wasn't really in that
mindset and then they came to me okay
listen and
here's the uh here's the ambulance
you're getting on it
um and you're going together tommy
came with me such a great friend um and
we took a 30 minute drive um
in la paz arrived and to
uh the place suddenly i have a free tour
retour exactly what can i ask for more
suddenly i have like
20 cameras in front of me like like
press
like talking to me asking me like how
are you feeling and i'm like
feel like crap and tommy's with me at
least he speaks some stat
some spanish um so they put me in put me
in a confinement
um for for whatever
it is the the time and the the consul
general
in bolivia gives me a call yaniv how are
you doing we
we we heard we were informed apparently
and so the day after i was on the front
page news of the bolivian newspaper
no um apparently they thought
it's good because we're in covet era so
people will actually understand this
apparently they thought that it was the
first case
of swine flu no way
in bolivia
put in confinement for two weeks i
wasn't allowed
to leave my room um and after two weeks
the only place they
let me go from there was to the ritz
carlton
because that was the only place they
like had a doctor right next to me so i
had to
you know i'm all like uh you know uh uh
muchi lair like
like stayed performing like hostels and
something i need to stay
like after confinement like a five star
hotel and needless to say that thomas
really
enjoyed it but uh but it was it was an
amazing
amazing story and you know eleven years
after
here we are in the world of of covet
and and social networks and everything i
can't i can't believe this story it's
it's just incredible and obviously
and everybody can resonate with what
you're saying but but back then i'm sure
that it was a little bit of a different
experience where pretty pretty much
nobody in the world
you know practically speaking was it was
going through
uh it was going through that so and that
that's just awesome yaniv
you you do so much uh from hebrew
university to singularity and
you you have a few incredible positions
also with the schusterman foundation but
now
you are responsible for the amazing
launch of bird
and the deployment of bird in israel and
with all of its challenges
with the the most frontal one that i can
think of
obviously yes there's logistics and yeah
and you know you're in economics and
that's all good and fun
but you're literally changing the way
people interact with their city
you know that's pretty an incredible
feat you are
redesigning the way people get from
point a to point b
both on a macro level but also on a
micro level this last
mile idea that has never been you know
solved and and you know we thought it
would take so long but
i'm able to get pretty much anywhere in
my city now because of this
can you tell me a little bit about why
you joined bird and how do you view this
big challenge what what is it that
excites you about this challenge
100 so i i i think you you said a few
things that i do want to connect i think
i did the executive program singularity
university and there they talk a lot
about like
um exponentialism versus versus the
linear
mindset and um and i looked for that
place where
where where that exponentialism really
lies exponential growth
that you take something that is is not
yet
in the mindset of people and you go from
zero to uh
to one hundred or one thousand or
whatever whatever it is
um and i remember uh sitting and on um
on bengali on boulevard um and right
next to my house with a dear friend
from los angeles sam rosen a
dear friend incredible entrepreneur and
we were sitting and talking about
talking about the future and looking
over the the bike lane in in bengalian
we see the private scooters
going by and then sam tells me you know
this company called
called bird and i said no but i think
this will be like
amazing in in israel um
and then essentially he connected me i
was
it was after a week i was already in
amsterdam
um and i actually like
actually and literally it was three
months after bird just
started to operate in the world they
were looking to grow wow
i met their patchwork now a dear friend
who started the
operations out of the us he was the
first employee i was the second employee
outside of outside of the u.s when i
came
to amsterdam we were working from coffee
shops they basically had to prove to
them why
you know tel aviv is a great place to
think about it bird
took a chance and i will never forget
like you know travis
founder taking a chance on tel aviv a
city of 420
000 people as being the first place to
launch outside of the us
alongside alongside paris and i
i remember you know it's not a trivial
thing
got to make it happen and then when i
was when i was basically there i said
this is
this is it like this can change you know
the way people get around into your
question
i didn't have a passion for for scooters
before to be honest
i never took a scooter ride before i
became
the general manager of a bird i just
really am intrigued about
solving problems and the way to solve
them
can be by a b c or d or t
or even you know z that we can't even
think about
at the moment and that that aha moment
that
scooters are the way to do it we already
saw it in tel aviv which
scooters have been big since 2016 and
israelis
as you know are incredible and early
adopters
startup yes so so that was you know
over one million cars enter tel aviv on
a daily basis so israelis don't take
that they'll find
a better way to get around and michael
100 that
better way to um to get around so i
always say
scooters is a is a mean to solve a
problem
and going from you know never riding a
scooter before
understanding that this can actually
solve a problem and now i'm like the mvp
of the company in terms of the number of
rides
that i am that i take because it
literally
is the best way to get around it changed
my life
therefore i can easily advocate it that
it
can change other people's life and i
always like to say like until you take
the first ride once you take the
first ride your life has changed um
forever
it's the most fun easy and best way to
get around
and i also think why why do people want
to get around inside these boxes
when you can get around outside in the
open air
look around you stop continue
there's no better way to get to know a
city than to do it by a bird and that's
what excites me
i have to tell you that ever since i
came back from palo alto here and i've
been taking them on a daily basis
i choose and i'm very you know i try to
be very efficient with my time
and i always you know do ways the
fastest route
all of a sudden i find myself doing
these massive detours on my bird
just so that i can breathe the air so
that i can see the neighbors so that i
can see the different things around me
stop and say hi to people it's it's an
incredible uh
feeling it reminds me nobody reminds me
of burning man in a lot of ways
i'm a big bernie man fan and it reminds
me of this personal aspect
we're not in these boxes we're everybody
together we're standing next to the
stoplight
and we're helping each other and we're
having this dialogue so i think it's
amazing
what have you learned about consumer
behavior since
you started onboarding here in tel aviv
what what interesting
insights do you can you tell about
people that you know we might not have
been able to think of before
bird came here wow so many
so many insights it's it's a daily you
know i i always you know
first of all looking at it and looking
at people right
you get certain insights and then
looking at the data you get
additional insights and i believe that
both of them together
and tell the the entire picture um
and i i love how people
have really just adopted it and
in a in a way that they tell me and and
i it totally makes sense to me a little
bit so a person tells me until
bird came i didn't even know how long it
i could leave the house
and i had to take like 20 minutes ahead
of time
yes please like but now you literally
can
time it in okay this will take me 12
minutes to get
to be all from my house and that will be
12 or 13 minutes but it's not going to
be i need to wait for the cab i need to
take out my car there'll be traffic
no you go in a seamless way you go
any time of the day and it's an
incredible
incredible practicum also like another
insight that was really
really amazing is that like every you
know every place has its
own specific insight so to me
and i i really think we can talk about
it more about like global perspective
and whatnot but
but i believe when you're in a certain
place you and you
and you live it you don't think about
certain things that are so trivial to
someone that comes from the outside
so there was a a an article that was
done and
about us the wall street journal
reporter came to israel
was was was doing an article about
something completely different
saw the micro mobility revolution that
that was here in bird
and decided to call up an editor we're
doing an art we're doing a piece
about about an about bird and micro
mobility in israel because it's a
phenomenon that
there is no place like it in the world
literally the city of the future
and the heading of the article was a
two-wheeled solution
for a traffic and shabbat
and you know the patterns that you see
on shabbat when there's no public
transportation
in israel you see different
rider patterns and during the weekend
versus
versus the week because people don't
have a different mode of transportation
and that also affects the way we
distribute the bird the way we think
about
the weekend and i think it it opens up a
lot of different
um options of mobility and that weren't
here before which essentially creates
and changes i i think for the better the
public
and the public sphere another thing that
i'm super proud of is
israel when you think about it in the
first two years of of our operations in
tel aviv we did over five and a half
million rides
350 000 unique users
and the most amazing thing that i'm
super proud of it and again is
someone that comes from the public
policy world and everything is
is the fact that we give the data to
cities and
then the cities can make smart decisions
about the public way so that the
tel aviv municipality came out with an
incredible 2025
bike plan and essentially the bike lane
that they did there the deputy mayor
came out and said
we did it based on the data that bird
gave them
so think about it never before was the
municipality able to get
such data that tells you exactly where
michael wants to get from point a to
point b
the it if it's bike lanes but if it's
even changing a
uh a uh bus stop for 20 meters from from
point a to point b when the
when the bus stops were made they were
made about like
data but not scientific data one-to-one
and here taking all that data
and putting it into the better use of
society is something that i'm super
super proud of bird in the way they act
i so inspired by this idea that you know
for dozens of years people are screaming
no bikes there's there's so many reasons
especially you know
inner city when there's high density of
course bikes is the way to go
and then you come here and you say you
know what we don't need
regulations we don't need the
municipality we see consumer shifts
be before eyes you're sitting in ben
gurion you know avenue
and you're watching consumers starting
to adopt this
thing that is ultra expensive it's a
hassle to take up the stairs every day
why and and then there's this connection
well there's this whole micro mobility
revolution that this is a perfect fit
for
you run this micro experiment which
turns into this global phenomena
bringing israel to the forefront of the
wall street journal on that end
and then having the municipality say oh
you proved to us you're onto something
we now
now we're buying into it and we're
customers of your data and making smart
decisions
that's exactly what i love about
innovation this is you know
exactly what excites me about it and i
can't imagine a better case study
to be learned than than you know showing
how you're aligning different incentives
these are incentives that couldn't be
aligned otherwise it would be extremely
extremely difficult you need
what excites you now so now we're in
2021 we're seeing
a lot of these on the street we're
seeing things advance constantly
what gets you excited right now what
gets me excited is
and you discussed a little bit before
but but i really believe
in like the win-win-win and i really
believe here that there is that
win for the the riders there's the win
for the cities there's the win
uh the win for for bird and everything
around it
and and what excites me is that we're
just getting started
so that win-win-win is already is
already here but if you think about it
really
in the history of the world bird
and bird started share these scooters
there was nothing
before that started it a little over
three years ago
so when you that's it it's been only
three years
it's been only four years and that's
what i always love to
remind people literally in three years i
believe we've created a
a revolution um and that usually takes
much much longer so if you think about
it in what we
we were able to achieve in three years
think about the next um three years
and think about where we'll be in 2025
and where cities will be in 2025.
if you think about all the different
revolutions moving from
carriages to cars etc they
they took time but but they were uh uh
an event that that lasted and that's
what i'm i'm excited about i'm excited
for
i really see like tel aviv is the city
of the future
but i'm excited to see the world going
that direction taking down
um cars from the road taking down um
emissions like over 30 percent of our
riders until they say they
they replace the car for taking that the
bird
that i i think i'm one of those i love
it and we're only
thank you and we're only getting started
because once
people really continue to understand
that phenomena
it will just continue to grow and the
whole industry will continue to
um to grow so i'm excited about seeing
where that will lead us and that that
just is
that just excites me thank you for being
so generous with your time and thank you
for
making this revolution happen it's very
rare that i get to
to talk to somebody and literally thank
them for changing my own life
not on a very small level but on a
little level you know you touched on
briefly but i think it's so powerful
this idea of consistency
in the most in one of the most
inconsistent habits that we have getting
from point a to point b
it's always a source of anxiety that
knowing okay like well let's track ways
quickly and let's see what the traffic
is like and let's take a buffer because
we have to park the car
and it's tel aviv so we can't park the
car and
now that i know that it literally takes
me five minutes and 41 seconds
on an average and i've done the math and
i have all the records
i know that i need six minutes to leave
the house and there
and you know the the worst surprise that
could happen is that i need to take one
street instead of another but it's the
exact same thing so yeah
thank you for for making my life a
little bit better or a lot better
actually
i have three fun questions are you ready
always
all right number one favorite subject in
school
favorite subject in school i have so
many things by the way to say about it
about the education the education system
um and which we can discuss in a
different
and in a we're already booking another
episode
i love it whenever whenever you want so
many so
so many things to talk about um but uh
but the thing that i loved him the most
was actually like drama we had a we had
a course on
on there on the drama i was a part of a
gifted gifted school and
and i'll never forget um like
how you take and create a play
when you're um when you're like in fifth
sixth grade and that tells us a lot more
than just
rehearsing something or writing it and
or writing it down
not that i'm a and again i love that
because it's so
interactive not because i'm in any way
um an actor or anything else the exact
opposite
but but what it does to you and what it
builds in you
and the entire component is something
that i will never forget
i love it one of your role models
fictional or real
so one of my role models um i will need
to say it's like
and is
someone that i am really look up to i i
think
first of all incredible leader that one
of the things we haven't had a chance to
talk about in this episode would be the
next episode is i i'm a true believer
in multi-disciplinary and
action so i believe that uh a real
leader
needs to experience a wide array
of things that's why i really love the
role of general manager
because you essentially need that
outlook
um of a lot of different things and i
think
if you look at robin's career and
whether being a you know an ambassador
um in washington
being um the chief um
in command of the israeli military and
being a warrior for peace
and he knew how to adapt in
any every single place and for the
betterment of society
um and again he had a lot of ego i think
a lot of years do have you go and that's
that's okay and understandable
but he put it to the betterment of
israel and the betterment
of um of society and for that for that i
am
i'm grateful and he wasn't he wasn't
afraid to
to change the way he was thinking
and and he wasn't stubborn and and
didn't go
into the wall and i think true leaders
need to have that i need to acknowledge
and sometimes that the path that they
took
is not the path that they need to take i
i love it and i love the lessons the
leadership lessons
in a very short span you managed to to
encompass some of the most
incredible insights of what what it
means to be a real leader and not just
on the paper or leader
and any of the most important hard
question
it's not really the most important but
it is the hardest three words
that you would choose to describe
yourself
wow to describe myself
or if i were to ask travis or patrick or
any of your employees here in israel
how would they describe you yaniv rivlin
i think a
community builder
a policy uh leaders and operations
um executor or executor
uh for that matter and uh i love it
and and and yeah and i think i think
the i i think that's another another
episode i i'm a true believer
in community building i think that's the
number one if you think about
think about bird for a second you have
so many different communities that you
need to cater for
you have you know the riders you have
the cities you have the chargers
you have yes you have ev everything
um you know cities is your number one
and number one customer
you always need to make sure that
everything works
in the right synergies and that
you execute to the best of your um to
the best of your ability because
people tend to forget that that this
role
it's not only putting the birds out it's
you mentioned it i think in the
beginning
it's an entire it's an entire operation
and it's enough for one thing to uh
to make it a slippery a slippery slope
so putting those things together
and is challenging but um but
is what makes the business what it is
right you need this was
amazing 20 minutes i don't think ever
went by this fast and i mean it
i have about a thousand more questions
that i didn't even start to
to think about asking right now because
we need to do maybe three or four more
episodes so look out for some calendar
invites but in the meantime
stay safe and stay healthy and then i
look forward to seeing you around tel
aviv
today
you